هذه الصور المباشره من بيروت
لمحاوله بعض المحتجين لاقتحام السراي
الحكومي
من المتقاعدين العسكريين اذا
[تصفيق]
والشرطه او قوى الامن اللبنانيه تمنع
هؤلاء من اقتحام السرايا الحكومي في بيروت
وهذه الصور اذا مشاهدينا هي صور مباشره
كما تلاحظون
لننسى بانه لبنان بالطبع يعاني من ازمه
اقتصاديه
قويه جدا وصفت بالاسوا وكان هناك انهيار
سريع لليره اللبنانيه من مستويات الالف
دولار الواحد الى مستويات فوق 100 الف
بنفس الوقت يوم امس وصلت الى 140 الف امام
الدولار
تسارع كبير بانهيار العمله المحليه وهذا
بالطبع لم ينعكس على اجور
القوى العامله خاصه بالقطاع العام
ولبنان يعاني من ارتفاع كبير في مستويات
الفقر
بعض المتظاهرين اذا
تجاوزوا الاسلاك الشائكه
مما دفع قوى الامن اللبنانيه الى التدخل
اذا هذه الصور
لمحتجين من المتقاعدين
العسكريين اذا يحاولون اقتحام السرايا
الحكومي في بيروت اعترادا بالطبع على
الاوضاع المعيشيه